ah oui j'avais simplement on a parlé d'
égalité
on a parlé aussi de territoires ruraux
et de communes rurales et il ya un sujet
sur lequel moi je souhaite que la
république à reviennent c'est la
question des temps d'activités
périscolaires dtap la réforme peillon
c'est une véritable catastrophe
la preuve manar en est faite l'école de
peillon ce n'est pas l'école de la
république
on creuse les inégalités dans les
territoires entre les communes qui ont
les moyens de proposer des été happé et
celles qui n'ont pas les moyens de
proposer c'était ap c'est pas notre
vision donc oui à l'égalité des chances
oui à l'égalité des enfants de la
république non à la réforme dtap donc
j'espère qu'on reviendra très très
rapidement 2007 sur cette mauvaise
réforme serait funeste pour nos enfants
et pour le territoire ruraux l'a dit